obviously there's a lot of life material
in this and I guess my question is at
what point does the life material yield
the story that you are trying to make a
little bit more Universal or did you
find that the more specific it was the
more universal it became that's exactly
what happened because I was very much
just trying to tell the story of my
mother and what what I thought was a
very unique character and it turns out
everybody's got one apparently but um ya
know I I was very moved by you know how
brave I thought it was that she had sold
the house and moved 3,000 miles and and
started her life over and the you know
the the setup of the story is all true I
mean and and so many of the details in
the movie are true I mean Susan wore my
mom stops from Chico's and uh drives my
dad's red car and his photo is my that's
my father and you know so there are so
many things in them in the film that are
that are true and based on truth and
then of course a ton of wish fulfillment
and I mean JK's character doesn't exist
yet he's probably out there will try but
no pressure no pressure but you know
that those are there's obviously
invention and I and I wanted to give her
a good time you know all the things that
my mother is sort of threatened to
volunteer at a hospital offered joy to
pay to pay for Joy's wedding you know
all the conversation happens yeah
there's a lot of truth but she was gonna
pay for your your wedding I can get
$13,000 to say no we talked about it for
a long time I kept using the excuse that
I was waiting for my baby weight to go
away for her to throw the wedding and
she still says she's four now when I'm
making it threaded I was just such a
generous spirit I mean so so much of
what makes the character great obviously
comes from my mother and then of course
Susan brought everything else to it and
made it an entirely different thing
how did Susan come into the show how did
you oh my god through God
I was sad because this was hard to get
made
yeah and joy and I were sad that it was
so tough to get a film about a woman I
guess of a certain age I don't know
where it's truly her story and not
directed by a woman produced by a woman
the doors didn't fly open for them to be
surprised
I don't know now it's a baby now it
would happen but I don't know it was it
was really tough at the time and and I
just wanted to send it to Susan so bad
that I just wrote a letter and sent it
cold to her agent unsolicited and we
were really lucky because Shanee Susan's
agent I when Lorene told me she wanted
to send it to Susan I said Shane E's
mother is like such a meddler she's
tweeting and facebooking all the time
about her like Long Island Jewish mother
that calls her all the time and I said
she's gonna love this you know and I
have to say like both JK and Susan's
agents you know to get a movie like this
made nobody gets paid up front as most
of you know in this audience and both of
their agents were so supportive and
loved this movie so much and really
helped us you know get it to you both
and um knew that it was an uphill battle
to get made but she was behind it you
know Susan do you remember when you
first heard about this or read the
script yeah I was moved by it and I
thought it was surprising usually um you
know within the first six pages you know
what's gonna happen and there were a lot
of little surprises in it and and then
but then and I met with Laureen and she
was so passionate about it which really
is important because I always ask a
director why do you want to make this
film and it's really supportive really
surprising how many don't have an answer
and she knew and then I got this great
little sizzle reel of her mom doing the
first five minutes of the film verbatim
shot by shot of what you see we should
run them side by side
and I just I was just like wow that
really that really was the final steps
because she was so great and and and
funny and sweet and you know I just was
like oh yeah so then we had to try to
find you know a cast and and the money
and everything else and JK got which was
really so exciting and then he got the
Academy Award and I called and I said oh
my god is he's still gonna do it I know
you sure he'll still do this little
thing and and he said yes and then Rose
was in and so that really was I don't
think it could have been made with
without everyone was excited to work
with Susan that honestly is how we got
such an incredible cast together I mean
but people came out of the woodwork to
just do one and all of those supporting
parts you know they're I mean like the
all the women and the stand-up comedians
and I mean that was really special yeah
applaud for them that JK I will never
make this mistake if I've made in the
past I won't make it going forward it's
not a motorcycle it's a Harley you
should never make that mistake
apparently Laureen wrote it I don't know
I never had been on one before so is
that true
you look like ya know what you're doing
well the miracle of acting and play :
the stunt man spending countless hours
teaching me how to write a first a dirt
bike and then a big road hog it looks
very good and what about the music
well yes the the very fundamental guitar
playing was actually performed by myself
yeah that's great
I remember you asked yes applaud I
remember you had asked how are you gonna
cover this because I really did learn
the song make sure I get the insert on
my left - oh that sweet frets even
though the name of the movie is the
meddler this is not a judgmental look at
this character in fact it's very loving
and we have seen a character like this
in many movies and it's comic foil or
held up to ridicule and it's very clear
from what you want to do and Susan the
way you
that this is not somebody you should or
even contemplate laughing at how
important was that in the very earliest
conversations with Susan about what you
wanted the essence of the performance to
be I mean we talked about certainly not
treating it like a broad
film and playing everything real and
this is a real person and these are you
know at least real reactions to
situations so we wanted to keep
everything grounded and honest and
vulnerable and unreal and and certainly
she's playing a character so all that's
very tough to do while nailing the
accent and among other things but I yeah
I mean that was just vital to telling
this kind of story I mean I got the
entire point of the title even though I
hope people don't you know get scared
off by it certainly is is to change what
it means to be a meddler like we should
have a meddlers Pride Parade and Men
Thursday is coming up and like you know
like that I'm it it's because of moms
caring so much and having a lot of love
to give and not knowing maybe what to do
is that when children are grown and
aren't asking for it as much though we
clearly need it and you know I just like
the idea that you get to see this woman
when or daughter's not calling her back
and you know that a lot of it comes from
loneliness and it's ultimately about
loneliness and trying to battle that by
making connections with people and also
getting over things and coping with
grief by caring for other people and how
you can feel better by making other
people feel better you know and it's
still not a selfless act yeah it is it
is a selfless act you know Susan you
have a chance to see the sizzle reel you
probably have a chance not only to wear
the outfits of but actually meet the
person who inhabited those clothes at
what point does that become do you
detach yourself from that you have all
this great reference you have Laurine
stories you have a screenplay but you
have to create a character how does that
evolution transpire I think you just
surrender and you don't think about it
from the outside I mean I was kind of
shocked when I did the first
dubbing and I saw him
self I was like oh my god she's crazy
and he's so patient Wow you know but I
think you just at a certain point you're
as the reen said you know you're playing
the reality and desperation is always
pretty funny and you don't comment on it
and you just trust that you know in the
editing that it's there and you don't
really think about it I think you just
have to open up and be vulnerable and go
for it in the rain when you're directing
that how do you surrender yourself
because this is a person you know very
clearly this is a character you've
written at what point do you back away
and let the actor do what she wants to
do like right when I met her but
probably no I mean we talked about it at
length and in terms of you know I
thought it was a constant discussion and
conversation and collaboration but it's
also Susan Sarandon so I you know really
was excited for her to take on this
character whatever pieces of it she felt
attached to I was also excited about but
it really just I think we were just in
sync honestly it didn't feel like it
wasn't a battle to be on the same page
it was clear the tone was clear by who
was cast and really she had so much more
to worry about then trying to tell me
not to beer be her mother because we
were shooting so fast we had you know it
was like tracting camp we were in the no
dressing rooms no you know it was all
very like hardcore just in and out few
takes
so everybody all the actors had to come
and they were prepared and when you see
what Rose did she was so emotionally
accessible and so ready to go and you
didn't get a lot of takes and you know
we just had to do it and so I don't once
we kind of started I don't think there
was a lot of like what Beatle did I like
in high school talk you know it was like
just do it and eat the egg and gonna do
it it was George though right
and JK was there a particularly
memorable off-duty motorcycle
hop on set security that you've you
found the soul of zipper in you know
what I yes and then you know like a lot
of people I've hung out with a lot of
those guys and and and they're always
great guys to talk to it looked exactly
like you yeah wouldn't they all have
that mustache and they're all super tan
and the way they sit on their motorcycle
on set yeah that's perfect
well they're out there in the Sun all
day and yeah and the mustache is left
over from the 70s when we all had them
yeah did I answer the question I kind of
did meet a guy I remember yeah like and
I and I actually we we were emailing or
texting back and forth about his name
and and and of course I've forgotten his
name but there was a guy not that I was
working with actually that was shooting
a few blocks from my house which people
insist on doing and and I just you know
what just went and they don't walked
over there and hung out with the guy and
he was very generous with you know
showing me the motorcycle and giving me
information and I was just pumping him
for you know character research Loreen
joy JK and Susan thank you so much for
coming in and thank you so much for sure